hi guys I'm Eric vos and this is a
breakdown of the Walking Dead Season 8
episode 13 do not send us astray but a
by all means please do send Henry astray
you know just right into the woods off
you go poof you know you guys did it
with Heath but in this case no one would
miss his freaking kid another thrilling
battle another pointless some thought
that undoes everything that is life on
The Walking Dead I guess now sure lots
of stuff confused me this episode as I'm
sure it did for you but you know what
let's break everything down and unpack
and explain everything that can be
unpacked and explained there were some
interesting details for serious that
might give this episode a whole new
meaning for you and let's start with the
big question brought to us on Twitter by
Jim what is it that Morgan supposedly
knows now Jim is referring to ghostly
Gavin's haunting taunts at Morgan you
know what it is now the answer of course
is black and yellow next question now
for real let's talk about this episode's
ending throughout the episode Morgan is
visited by a hallucination of Gavin who
repeats phrases you know what it is and
you were supposed to now on the surface
this is Morgan's own subconscious
telling him that he was supposed to
execute Gavin not the little young Henry
and now he's feeling guilty for his
violent insanity his clearness inspiring
the same sort of blind vengeance in the
younger generation but on a deeper level
this episode itself kind of tells us
what it is the final three lines of the
episode are Gavin screaming you know
what it is you know followed by Diane
asking Maggie what is it and Maggie
watching her people get buried responds
the cost and if you look closely at
these scenes as part of a larger meta
conversation you get your answer it is
the cost the cost of selfish vengeance
driven decisions
Maggie admitted that she brought the
battle inside the hilltop walls so that
Glen's grave would be the last thing
negan sees a move motivated by vengeance
the cost of that well she made it easier
for the Savior's Walker blood-covered
weapons to infect more of her people
Rick admitted to Maggie that he went
rogue and t-bone negan trying to finish
him off
he was motivated by vengeance for Carl's
death the cost of that well Meighan got
separated from his pack allowing the
more bloodthirsty simon to take the lead
and depriving maggie of that justice
that she wanted and morgan reacted to
Benjamin's death last season by
reverting to his psychotic killing
streak using his new sharpened spear to
slaughter Savior after Savior while
clearing the kingdom the cost of that
well dumb-dumb Henry follows in his
footsteps letting blind vengeance guide
him into making the idiotic decision to
open the prisoner gate and allowing
saviors to easily overpower him and
escape so that's the general idea here
guys when tragedy strikes and you lose
someone do you react by seeking
vengeance and doing things just to make
you feel good in the short term well
there's a cost to that usually it means
even more violence and unnecessary loss
of life but all of this connects to the
deeper meaning of the episode which I
will get to at the end of this video but
for now there's actually a second big
question a lot of you guys asked about
including Jordan on Twitter is Tara
infected during the battle Simon was
creeping up on Tara but Dwight shot her
in the shoulder with an arrow before
Simon could get there this is all
overseen by Daryl who interpreted it as
Dwight's betraying them showing his true
nature whereas Tara was cool with it for
some reason it's weird it's kind of like
Daryl and Tara kind of knocked their
heads together and swapped out looks all
of a sudden everyone's conclusion was
that because Tara got a flesh wound by a
savior weapon she would turn just like
everyone else did but maybe not before
the arrow was fired Dwight turned down
the chance to kill Tara leaving it to
Simon his decision to shoot air in the
shoulder only really makes sense if
Dwight actually wanted to spare her life
unlike the other Savior's we never saw
Dwight soak his arrows and Walker blood
and considering his duel loyalties
there's reason believed that arrow was
actually clean and yes I know this whole
question of whether or not Walker blood
can really affect people without them
getting bitten is a little confusing
considering season 2 revealed that
everyone is already infected and that
over the seasons pretty much everyone at
some point on the show has probably
gotten Walker blood in their mouth
in open wounds any way to check out my
breakdown of episode 11 for more details
on this whole topic but terror situation
here makes more sense if you compare
this episode to the comics but it's kind
of a spoiler so if you don't want to
know skip to this time so you don't get
mad at me for spoiling things for you
okay
this episode was adapted from the events
of issues 123 and 124 in the comics much
of the battle came from the art of those
panels including the move to suddenly
blind the saviors with floodlights but
that battle ends with Rick getting shot
with Dwight's arrow causing a scare that
Rick would be infected and turn into a
walker but then we learned that Dwight's
arrow was actually clean and that Rick
is okay it's one of the primary ways
Dwight proves that he can be trusted
this show could be adapted in this
storyline with Tara she and Daryl more
than anyone still hate Dwight so if they
learn that this arrow is clean that
could be a big turning point for them
now I'll say that if the show plans to
use this whole clean arrow twist on Tara
instead of Rick that would change the
way we look at that mysterious closing
shot at the end of episode 9 if not from
Dwight's arrow why is Rick wounded I
still predict this moment is following a
final battle against negan but something
else would have had to have caused this
I got shot let me know what you think in
the comments below but for now let's
move on speaking of Dwight's arrow
hitting Tara it's interesting that it's
the same way that Dwight killed the
person Tara is avenging Denise let's
look back at the other ways this episode
connected to past episodes intersection
callbacks
now Tara's forgiving attitude this
episode is due to her suddenly
remembering her own past as a turncoat
she and Daryl discuss how she used to be
with the governor and how she really
benefited from their people allowing
Redemption they also bring up Merle
Darryl's brother who was with the
governor as well
now I thought was interesting how Daryl
admitted that if not for Rick
the two brothers probably would have
ended up with the Savior's just like how
we saw with Morales earlier this season
all of these survivors could have easily
ended up in a plundering cult in a
slightly different series of events this
whole episode seemed very aware of that
past prison era this episode's nighttime
internal outbreak very much echoed the
season 4 episode infected where the
sickness caused chaos throughout the
prison and Morgan's hallucinations of
Gavin certainly
the season 5 episode when Tyrese
hallucinating the ghosts of Beth and
Myka and Lizzy and the governor we saw
the death of Tobin this episode so it
makes sense that these scenes would
remind us of the last time he was really
important on the show Carol tells him
sorry for how I left she's referring to
that time they dated hey remember that
that was in season 6 when she broke it
off with him with that goodbye letter
this episode also continued to
time-honored traditions on the Walking
Dead
first the bizarrely high death rate of
doctors on this show which I have
compared to in the past to the defense
against the dark arts professor job when
it comes to turnover we've seen the
deaths of dr. s at the prison Pete and
Alexandria Denise dr. Emmett Carson in
the sanctuary and his brother Harlan
Carson recently and now Dana the
Kingdom's doctor the show is going out
of its way to clarify that Sadiq it's
the only person left in the world with
any medical training
I guess there's that a dr. Stephens guy
back from the hospital in season 4 or
he's probably around somewhere
but Sadiq partly killed him right
because this is a Walking Dead and
doctors are Highlanders there can be
only one the second tradition is carols
terrible relationships with children
right miss Sophia and Lizzie and mica
Sam and now Henry every kid who even
looks at Carroll drops dead witch yeah
that's my prediction for where Henry is
by the way when an episode ends with
Carol looking for a kid the most
plausible guess is that the kid is dead
inside a barn right all right moving on
to quick details that I want to point
out this episode that I found
interesting a lot of you were confused
why the doors and windows were left open
at the hilltop for walkers to just kind
of walk in and spread the infection well
in the scene with Rick and Michonne Rick
explains that they need to open up
everything so the rooms crowded with
Kingdom and Alexandria soldiers don't
overheat overnight yeah that makes sense
but you know what also would've been
smart to keep a guard awake overnight
right you know to wake up everyone when
walkers start attacking them or loudly
falling down stairs right next to them
well you may have also noticed the
recurring close-ups of clocks this
episode there was the grandfather clock
when Henry stole the gun the digital
clocks on the bedside beside Tobin and
Dana's wristwatch the director used
these to convey the hours pass same as
the infection to cold but on a deeper
level this imagery
combined with the subtle ticking sound
effect in the music of the episode
created this tension as if time was
running out for all these characters
let's also talk about some of the ways
this episode drew on cultural influences
and our segment under the influence I
love the way this episode showed us a
shot of the full moon right before
Tobin's death in turn they used a
classic horror movie trope for werewolf
mythology the visual signal warning of a
human's coming in Supernatural
transformation and I thought it was also
interested in how simon's response to
Maggie regarding the savior prisoners
was that his organization prizes people
who avoid capture now in real world war
leaving a man behind is at best a last
resort it's almost unthinkable because
it completely demoralized as your troops
if your ranks realize that their lives
mean nothing to you they lose their will
to fight so first Simon to brazenly
declare this abandonment as a sort of
like principle or rationale it's a
terrible idea it's not that surprising
for Alden and a few other saviors to
break ranks like they did and if Simon
glibly saying he prefers people who
don't get captured reminds you of any
other real world leaders hopefully
neither of those leaders will be in
charge much longer right and in case you
were wondering sadik's prayer for the
dead that he tells Rick about is
actually a real Muslim funeral prayer
it's a really a prayer for the mourners
themselves that they honor the deceased
person's memory and not lose themselves
in grief and that brings us to the
deeper meaning this episode titled after
a line from city express do not send us
astray in this episode several
characters were led astray by their
grief for lost loved ones
Maggie by Glenn Rick by Carl Morgan and
Henry by Benjamin and that led them to
make brash decisions that led to
unnecessary losses the cost of learning
the wrong lessons from those deaths and
letting vengeance take over this
episodes first half showed team Rick and
Maggie well prepared for a savior attack
a solid horn alarm system and effective
spike strip Daryl cleaning up with his
dope handlebar mounted machine gun and a
hilltop booby-trapped with or a ramming
bus and blinding flood lights but
Gavin's ghost reflected the nagging flaw
in each of the
mine's the bloodthirst they can't shake
and as their battle-plan fell apart
their own desires for vengeance sent
them astray and let's check in with this
episode's killcount
unlike previous two episodes there was a
lot of bloodshed this episode bullets
flew and dozens died on both sides but
from my count Darrel was the deadliest
he had at least nine kills Savior's
combined with Walker's so here's my
question for you guys actually who do
you think has been the most frustrating
character to watch on The Walking Dead
over the years characters like Terra and
Spencer Andrea Gabriel were very good at
driving us mad with their back-and-forth
behavior and to be fair to the actors
most of this is just kind of like
inconsistent writing this episode I just
cannot get past Henry guys two episodes
ago Morgan told him that Gavin killed
his brother we thought it was done we're
good we're ready to move on now I get
that Henry might not have believed
Morgan but when did Henry ever vocalize
or convey the skepticism it just came
out of nowhere and where the hell did he
get the key to open the prison gate oh
look I'm serious wherever Henry
disappeared - just leave him there don't
make it so easy for the haters to hate
on the show right okay now but I want to
know what you guys think comment down
below tweet me directly ID a vos and
follow new rock stars on Twitter for
updates on our videos and yeah like this
video and subscribe to this channel for
all of our walking dead coverage and
definitely go check out my breakdowns of
all the past episodes this season for
all the explanations of the stuff that
you missed guys thanks for watching and
see you next week bye